weirdest species coming 1995 two years
old was all species no it's probably
actually worse that you saw it at five
because you could never
I have arrived with my chair
John has arrived a little earlier than
me for the trailer of a rival yeah puns
are a classic form of comedy Amy Adams
is in this I am in one of Laughlin
studios right now that's right Amy Adams
was trained hey so I will be just as
good a roundabout way into to here I
basically Amy Adams yeah you should be
the princess enchanted or two that's how
you know you're really good actors let's
not listen to you a while ago this shows
a minute long without this define your
story and your life like the day they
are
who rap Colonel Thank You Banks language
is the first weapon drawing the conflict
it's quite a greeting everyone comes to
translations
not everyone is wired for what you're
about to do so where is it you'll see
soon enough
every
oh [ __ ] denis villeneuve you did it yeah
damn make a wish in theatres 11 11 16
hashtag why are they here they got lost
the way don't work interesting they
broke down zipping across the galaxy
didn't plan the trip yeah
someone needs to take a [ __ ] in the back
but I do like prisoners prisoners and
that other movie where Jake Gyllenhaal
plays two people and didn't say sorry oh
sorry oh wait wait in order for me to
tell this joke I need to find that the
character name real fast
you betcha John Wow
so we got I'm so ready can I hope you're
even waiting joke oh we got Lois Lane
and we got Hawkeye and we got Dan
Smithson
what's Forest Whitaker's character and
species oh yeah I could have gone better
great joke I gotta say when Forest
Whitaker said that line though didn't
believe it yeah like that doesn't sound
like the choice of words someone would
use in that situation I'm like you're
standing inside of this thing it seems
as though they have a right you arrived
game's way for them about the wall
they've arrived you've arrived so now
they have to arrive just in yeah not the
ship and they're gonna come back where
did they land that's gorgeous looking I
love sci-fi movies like this into sci-fi
movies that are telling a big story but
on clearly like a smaller scale unless
we get a second trailer and it's like
overblown with an accident
this is gonna become Promethea yeah but
currently this is more of the tone and
the style of what we're getting I think
of movies like sunshine yeah okay yeah I
think it was like sunshine which are
which is like technically was like a
low-budget sci-fi film but it's feels
big though and it feels it feels huge
but it still rather contained that this
feels even significantly more contained
in sunshine and I feel like they could
do a lot more with it it's cool to see a
sci-fi movie where you're like this
looks like the performances from the
main casts are gonna be very vital to
this film working yeah much about the
alien special effects and all that [ __ ]
like it's good to have a little
mysterious intrigue yeah well and it's
nice to see them going into a realm of
sci-fi where it is kind of bending like
we have a lot of hyper naturalistic
sci-fi right now where it's like you
know especially since district 9 came
out and stuff like that we like things
that are immediate and grungy a
thought-provoking yeah and this looks
like it at least could be
thought-provoking I mean seeing his
other films there's a lot of character
and a lot of plot in there so I'm
curious especially because of the
director but you know that whole shot
where they walk in and they're upside
down and it's kind of yeah there's no
gravity and they're kind of bending the
rules of physics like I really like when
sci-fi goes there in a curious or
intriguing way you know and not just as
an excuse to fire lasers pretty cool
teaser though I want to see more they're
doing that thing where they'd like right
before they're about to show you they
cut away and now I want to see it so
good and I gotta say Amy Adams this
looks like she's doing a much better job
than her powerhouse performance in films
such as Batman V Superman and Man of
Steel Oh a totally this could be a whole
new defining character I hope Amy Adams
is good like I want to see her be able
to use the range I know she has and I've
seen this face a lot recently from her
and they
that this movie gives her a rich enough
character yeah yeah cuz this is a good
bunch of at least the cast we see here
like they're a good bunch I think Jeremy
Renner and Amy Adams in the same movie
together
that's so great that's a great idea I
think like just knowing the films are
seeing Jeremy around I've seen I've seen
films that are not The Avengers that
he's done well in legacy did they have
any scenes in American hustle together I
think they interacted cheering they're
like or twice but this looks like what
this is clearly they're the two main
stars in each film I think that's a
great pairing because Jeremy Renner he's
a very very talented actor and he knows
how to worked in films that also really
involved just using your imagination
yeah and Amy Adams to do the same thing
as well so you put the two together who
know how to give powerhouse emotional
performances weird act with being an
imaginative world and Forest Whitaker
King of Scotland one of the best
fictional pieces I've ever seen like he
created a whole character I did nothing
nothing to work off yeah nothing no no
history no mystery no nothing no
real-life atrocities and then he came
out like a year later with a
Schwarzenegger film The Last Man Last
Stand see I feel like we're cresting
into a nice time where maybe now again
people are starting to invest in
interesting you know mid budget you know
science fiction movies and stuff like
that I don't know based on the story
story of your life written by Ted young
I'm an Asian guy yeah GI I thought about
that as this trailer began I was like I
wonder if this is based on a book or
whatever all the aliens or relations
sometimes there are Chinese people from
the future who time traveled through a
wormhole
like Cloud Atlas not like Cloud Atlas
like Timecop with jean-claude van Damme
so this guy who wrote it it's written
several horror films actually yeah which
is which is cool it could be a nice
touch
I like sci-fi horror oh that would be
cool that's I guess that's why I kind of
got even though like it looks and feels
different than sunshine for some reason
sunshine did come to mind yeah there is
something dready and imposing underneath
all this yeah it seems like it feels
like there will be some scary [ __ ] that
will probably go down
yeah and Dennis films tend to have a
little of intensity to them too yeah it
seems like and then hey I mean like the
the writer of this piece has written
some things that I wasn't too keen on
but I really liked lights out a lot and
I hope that this is like paired with
this director I hope they can create
something really cool although I got to
say there was already an alien movie
called the arrival early that stars
Charlie Sheen oh boy we should watch a
double feature I've seen it sonna Peters
is it good that's when the aliens knees
go backwards
what oh it's like they're they look like
humans when they run there it needs to
worship a pop backwards in there stop
running away I'm not making a joke it's
a real it's a real thing
hey you're timing the arrival movie
trailer what comes up in the recommended
next is a rival official teaser
perfect to remake it's a remake of a
great classic Charlie Sheen film and
they couldn't get him to come back
everyone certainly right I know that's
weird you know what it's career yeah
he's tamper with his image I know just
like how Mel Gibson couldn't come back
for Mad Max now Charlie Sheen can't come
back for the sequel to the arrival all
right all right
hey there's movement in the Fast and the
Furious Fast injuries yes either take
away or add of the when you want to let
people know you're serious yeah yeah
it's the way I'm doing a sequel but also
reinventing it when we eventually come
back we're just gonna be real rejects
not the Blair Witch Project Blair Witch
not Batman V Superman just V new this
channel you can subscribe today get a
subscription services $49.99 a month
with a down payment of $50 you
unlimited access to the reactions
University Eric is on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook comm slash the
real rejects he runs that [ __ ] and he
also runs facebook.com slash blue house
and shout out to all the toilets toilets
if you're listening one day we will win
we will take back the earth we have
access to the world's most powerful
water system the one that you are
connected to an interlocking series of
tubes yeah he loves you too and before
you flush it or else it'll clog yeah you
should be good to your toilet it
provides a very necessary service I
don't have to take a bucket outside
anymore or diggle anymore anymore